[Musique]
c'est pas le carburant
c'est pour le carburant mettez vous sur
cette pile là je vais décale de la file
bloque le passage
pour leur donner un coup de main
regardez maintenant les mamie elles
peuvent traverser tranquillement
[Musique]
ça veut dire nous on est là pour la
bienveillance que tout le monde mette
son carburant tranquillement et il y a
des fils aussi par exemple là-bas ils
vont attendre deux heures là-bas 3h
parce que déjà
on fait passer les voitures deux par
deux comme ça tout le monde a le même
temps d'attente après généralement le
temps d'attendre c'est quoi c'est 20
minutes sinon ça me fait des heures deux
heures trois heures
[Musique]
j'ai dit heureusement qu'ils sont là
c'est super franchement c'est magnifique
[Musique]